I'm about to become the
new duke!
You might wanna tell Morag
to startpolishing that crown.
I certainly will not be doing that.
♪ I used to feel like a nobody ♪
♪ 'Cause my sisters always
Steal the spotlight♪
♪ But now I know that I can be
somebody♪
♪ The most special Loud in allthe land♪
♪ I'm gonna turn some headsaround♪
♪ Make everybody know my name♪
♪ I'll bring a little loud
Into this quiet place♪
♪ And no one's ever
Gonna steal my spotlight ♪
♪ I'll be the talk of thetown♪
♪ This comic book's gotta go
Ace Savvy's all you should know♪
♪ Have abreakfast burrito on me♪
♪ Step right up tomy show
For some magic and gold♪
♪ You canthank me later, 'cause♪
♪ I'm gonna bethe duke♪
♪ It's my time, my turn tobe♪
♪ The new duke in history♪
♪ Gonna show myfamily♪
♪ I'm ready to rule♪
♪ I'm gonna be the duke♪
♪ When you help out otherpeople
Don't just do it to be in thespotlight♪
♪ Or be the talk of thetown♪
♪ Remember everything you do
It's about them and not you♪
♪ That's howyou live like a Loud♪
♪ If you want to wearthe crown
Go makethis town a betterplace♪
♪ Look into their hearts
And make some real change♪
♪ 'Cause magictricks and short-termfixes
Are not theanswer♪
♪ You've gotta do some good deeds♪
♪ I hear you loud and clear
I have to act more sincere♪
♪ That's the secretfor me to win♪
♪ 'Cause if I do thisright
I'll be in the spotlight♪
♪ You canthank me later, 'cause…♪
♪ He's gonna be the duke♪
♪ It's my time, my turn to be♪
♪ The new duke in history♪
♪ Gonna show myfamily♪
♪ I'm ready to rule♪
♪ He's gonna be the duke♪